dimanche après-midi deuxième et dernier
jour de compétition pour ses skieurs ils
sont âgés de 35 après de 80 ans et ont
tous réussi la sélection pour participer
à cette finale de ski nautique figure
sur un monoski est tiré par un bateau
les concurrents doivent effectuer le
plus de figures possibles en seulement
deux fois 20 secondes
qui permet de faire les figures avec le
palonnier à la main et puis sur ce
palonnier il y a aussi une sangle qui
permet de
d'être au tracté par le biais et de ne
plus avoir l'appui que sur une jambe
voilà ok
qu'importe la catégorie d'âge dans
laquelle ils évoluent tous les skieurs
s'affrontent sur le même parcours mais
cette fois-ci les conditions météo sont
difficiles est-ce que satisfait de votre
performance non il y a trop de vent un
peu de clapot on disait pas dans de
bonnes conditions pour pour faire un bon
parcours quoi ça c'est pas trop mal
passé malgré les vagues au retour mais
c'est pas facile mais ça a été le fait
qu'il y a beaucoup de ventes ça fait du
clapot sur l'eau et c'est assez
difficile pour prendre les prises de
cartes quand on s'écarte et notamment la
sur mon deuxième parcours dernière
figure j'ai pas osé la faire parce que
j'avais vraiment peur des vagues une
difficulté dont tient compte le jury à
l'aide de caméra il visionne en direct
sur des écrans le passage des
concurrents des points sont attribués à
chaque figure selon différents critères
important après c'est le backback ouais
déjà la façon dont elle est faite si
elle est si le ski est tourné à fond si
le il est décollé de la vague enfin bon
il y a plein de choses quoi ça s'apprend
au fur et à mesure le ski nautique un
sport qu'on associe souvent à la mer
alors que ce n'est pas son terrain de
prédilection en réalité pour le ski
nautique de compétition en général on
est plutôt sur des plans d'eau fermée
abrités ou des rivières très calmes pour
que la glisse soit de bonne qualité le
week-end se termine avec les podiums et
la remise des médailles des athlètes
qu'on retrouvera peut-être au
championnat d'Europe de ski nautique
senior en septembre à La Teste de bûche